[Música]
El Congreso de Perú destituyó a su
presidenta Lady camones el pleno aprobó
una moción de censura presentada en su
contra tras la difusión de unos audios
que presuntamente comprueban que estaría
concertando la aprobación de leyes con
el jefe de su partido Alianza para el
progreso
la policía de Canadá encontró sin vida a
uno de los dos sospechosos de haber
asesinado a 10 personas con un arma
blanca en una comunidad indígena de
zascatchewan su hermano el otro
sospechoso sigue en la fuga pero las
autoridades creen que está herido y que
busca atención médica
un palito independiente se encargará de
revisar los documentos incautados por el
FBI de la mansión del ex presidente
Donald Trump en Florida así lo determinó
una jueza Federal que fue designada por
el propio Trump en 2020 antes de que
dejara la presidencia a medida había
sido solicitada por los abogados del ex
mandatario
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en francés 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Perú con un nuevo episodio de la crisis
política que vive el país la presidenta
del Congreso Lady camones fue destituida
con 61 votos a favor 47 en contra y 5
abstenciones el pleno aprobó una moción
de censura en su contra presentada con
la firma de 23 congresistas y
agrupaciones de izquierda la medida se
dio tras la publicación de una serie de
audios que probarían que comunes estaba
concertando la aprobación de leyes con
el jefe de su partido César Acuña y por
eso se pidió que sea censurada por
varias faltas entre ellas atentar contra
la constitución política Acuña habría
presionado a camones para que aprobara
una ley para la creación de un Distrito
lo que habría favorecido en su
candidatura a gobernador de la región de
la Libertad en el norte del país
del gobierno entre tanto el presidente
peruano Pedro Castillo acudió al
despacho de la fiscal general de la
nación para responder sobre los
presuntos delitos de encubrimiento
personal organización criminal y tráfico
de influencias a través de las seis
investigaciones para eliminar es que
pesan en su contra desde que asumió el
poder en julio de 2021 Ariana villacorta
nos cuenta más
el presidente de Perú Pedro Castillo
compareció ante la fiscalía por los
presuntos delitos de tráfico de
influencias en la compañía Estatal
petroperú y por encubrimiento personal y
organización criminal que surgieron a
raíz del despido del entonces ministro
del interior Mariano González caso por
el cual también están siendo
investigados preliminarmente el Primer
Ministro Aníbal Torres y el ministro de
justicia y derechos humanos félixchero
desde este lunes durante la diligencia
que se extendió por unas tres horas y
que se llevó a cabo en la sede del
Ministerio Público Castillo no respondió
a las preguntas que le hizo la fiscal
Patricia Benavides reiterando la
estrategia que ha utilizado en
interrogatorios anteriores hemos negado
no solamente hemos negado tajantemente y
hemos rechazado esas imputaciones sino
que pedimos que se hagan todas las
investigaciones
una vez
se acopia todo estas investigaciones
iremos nosotros a seguir colaborando con
la justicia a las afueras de las
instalaciones simpatizantes y
detractores esperaban al jefe de estado
algo que evidencia la polarización en el
país andino
judicial es una vergüenza tener un
presidente con tantas causas judiciales
hay de todo corrupción y tráfico de
influencias hay de todo el presidente
peruano acumula seis investigaciones
abiertas en su contra 5 de ellas a cargo
de la fiscal Benavides Esto además de la
crisis política económica y social que
atraviesa Perú ha llevado a la oposición
a pedir en varias ocasiones su renuncia
destitución y adelanto de elecciones
Esta última opción empezará a ser
discutida en el congreso el martes
en Brasil a menos de un mes de las
elecciones presidenciales las encuestas
continúan dándole una ventaja al
expresidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
quien Busca un nuevo mandato de acuerdo
con datos de la consultora ipec el
mandatario contaría con el 44% de apoyo
frente al 31% de Jair bolsonaro quien
Busca la reelección de haber segunda
vuelta Lula ganaría con el 52% de los
votos mientras bolsonaros se quedaría
con el 36%. el mandatario ha dicho que
solo aceptará los resultados de los
comicios si son limpios sembrando dudas
sobre el sistema electoral del país en
reiteradas ocasiones
en Canadá ya son 11 los fallecidos tras
uno de los ataques más violentos de la
historia del país Incluyendo a uno de
los presuntos responsables las
autoridades encontraron el cuerpo de
demian sanderson uno de los sospechosos
del apuñalamiento masivo que cobró la
vida De 10 personas y que dejó otras 19
heridas la policía sigue buscando a su
hermano sanderson que sigue fugado desde
el domingo el Primer Ministro canadiense
Justin trudeado envió un mensaje de
pésame a los familiares y a la comunidad
y lamentó que hechos como estos se hayan
vuelto demasiado comunes en el país
Manuel acano con los detalles
uno de los hermanos sanderson fue
encontrado sin vida Los Dos sospechosos
de la puñalamiento múltiple en el que 10
personas murieron y 19 resultaron
heridas en una comunidad indígena al
noreste del país habían huido tras uno
de los ataques más violentos en la
historia reciente de Canadá puede Demi
en sanderson fue encontrado cerca al
lugar de los hechos su cuerpo fue
localizado al aire libre en una zona con
muchos césped en las proximidades de una
casa que estaba haciendo investigada
podemos confirmar que tiene varias
heridas visibles la búsqueda continúa
cientos de agentes siguen tras el rastro
de miles sanderson aseguran que podría
estar en la ciudad de Regina la capital
de sascachihuan y que es probable que
esté herido el segundo de los Anderson
había infringido su libertad condicional
una condena que estaba cumpliendo por
los delitos de asalto robo conducta
maliciosa y amenazas
los habitantes de la comunidad siguen
conmocionados
no esperaba despertarme el domingo
escuchando esto Ahora estoy aterrorizada
de irme a dormir por la noche
aterrorizada de abrir mi puerta el
Primer Ministro canadiense Justin
trudell continuó el ataque y aseguró que
está trabajando con las autoridades
locales los ataques de ayer en son
impactantes y desgarradores mis
pensamientos y los pensamientos de todos
los canadienses están con aquellos que
han perdido a sus seres queridos Y con
aquellos que están heridos este tipo de
violencia o cualquier tipo de violencia
no tiene cabida en nuestro país las
cifras de apuñalamientos fatales en
Canadá han ido Un aumento en los últimos
años en 2021 se registraron 242 más de
los 237 reportados en 2020 en noticias
de Estados Unidos son perito
independientes revisará los documentos
incautados por el FBI durante la redada
a la residencia del ex presidente
estadounidense Donald Trump en Florida
tal como lo habían solicitado los
abogados del ex mandatario la decisión
fue tomada por la jueza Federal Canon
quien fue designada por Trump en el
cargo en 2020 justo unos meses antes de
que dejara la presidencia los detalles
con nuestro corresponsal en Washington
Cristóbal Vázquez la jueza eiling Canon
aprobó el nombramiento de un maestro
especial para revisar los documentos a
recuperados por el FBI en maralago y
también prohibió temporalmente que el
departamento de Justicia use este
material para cualquier investigación
contra de Donald Trump hasta que
precisamente el maestro especial revise
los 11.000 documentos recuperados la
orden de la jueza nombrada por Trump
evitaría al menos por ahora que los
fiscales federales usen pruebas clave
mientras continúen investigando si el
presidente si el ex presidente Trump
retuvo ilegalmente documentos de
seguridad nacional o se obstruyó los
repetidos esfuerzos del gobierno para
que este devolviera estos documentos
confidenciales el departamento de
Justicia había advertido ya que apelaría
la decisión ante la Corte de apelaciones
del circuito 11 lo que pasa es que en
esta corte nombró seis de los 11 jueces
activos ahora entonces los abogados de
Trump y el departamento de Justicia
tienen hasta el próximo viernes para
presentar una lista de candidatos y
empezar así este proceso que sería largo
de hecho demorará sin duda la
investigación aunque ya el FBI haya
revisado todos los documentos
encontrados
seguimos en Estados Unidos que celebró
el día del trabajo el presidente Joe
biden arremetió nuevamente contra su ex
rival Donald Trump de visita en West
midfly Pensilvania el actual inquilino
de la Casa Blanca se dirigió a líderes
sindicales en busca de apoyo para las
elecciones de medio término en noviembre
en las que los demócratas se arriesgan a
perder sus estrechas mayorías en ambas
cámaras del congreso byden quiso
diferenciar a los republicanos
tradicionales de quienes apoyan a Trump
asegurando que se debe tomar una
decisión entre un mejor país y el camino
del extremismo en México la guardia
nacional descubrió a 180 migrantes
irregulares que viajaban en dos
autobuses en una carretera por el estado
de Veracruz se trata de personas
provenientes de países de Centroamérica
y Cuba y que pedían ayuda a las
autoridades para evitar ser deportadas a
sus territorios de origen los dos
autobuses Fueron incautados por los
uniformados junto con otro vehículo y un
arma de fuego y además detuvieron a tres
personas la situación se da justo días
después de que 9 migrantes murieran
cuando intentaban cruzar el río Grande
hacia Estados Unidos cerca de Texas
hasta que este Informativo en las 24
Gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]